i am all in on sending humans to mars
there is nothing i want to achieve more
in my career than seeing humans step
foot on that planet because i know it
could be the start of humanity spreading
into the cosmos i'd be happy to be that
first person on mars but my wife thinks
that a three-year vacation to a deserted
planet with no oxygen no real atmosphere
nothing to eat or drink freezing
temperatures bone depleting gravity and
space radiation is a bad idea
for some reason
so i'll settle for sending someone else
in fact maybe some of you watching this
could be the first to go to mars
okay so i'm going to tell you why we
should go to mars and why we should
spread humanity into the rest of the
solar system
i'll also show you that by setting out
on the next great age of space
exploration will actually make earth a
much better place to live as well but
before we do that i want to tell you
about something that happened very
recently that i am very excited about we
made oxygen on mars
i work on the mars 2020 rover
perseverance is what it's called or
percy for short my role on the mission
is to help one of the instruments on
board called moxie make oxygen from the
atmosphere on mars
i am fortunate to be part of the
excellent team that has made moxie a
reality moxie stands for the mars oxygen
isru experiment isru stands for in-situ
resource utilization
don't ask me why we chose to put an
acronym within an acronym
sometimes we make bad decisions in life
what this all means is that moxie takes
the carbon dioxide in the atmosphere of
mars and converts it into oxygen it's
kind of like a tree on mars doing
photosynthesis
moxie is helpful for two reasons
one is you gotta breathe but there's
actually a second reason that requires
way more oxygen than breathing and
that's rocket propellant
rockets burn a lot of propellant so we
have to make a lot of oxygen without
oxygen we can't breathe we can't move we
can't explore
i am in charge of sending commands to
the rover to make oxygen on mars we
package up commands to tell percy what
to do the next day and percy listens and
does what we ask
well most of the time anyway
i know this is going to be recorded and
a lot of people will watch this after
the fact but it's really exciting
because we actually just made oxygen for
the first couple of times on mars in the
past couple of months the first time we
did it was a pretty historic moment
and now that we've made oxygen i can't
wait to explore what's next
okay so
why should you want to go to mars and
explore the rest of the solar system and
what are we going to do about all those
issues my wife pointed out about mars
it doesn't sound like a great place to
go and there's a million problems we
could be solving here on earth with our
time and money instead right
i want you to imagine in the past a
group of people that live on a south
pacific island
they've been there isolated for over a
thousand years living generation after
generation they had no idea what was
across the water and it was incredibly
dangerous to try an expedition to go
find out one day the volcano that had
formed the island initially erupted and
wiped out the entire civilization on the
island in one day
their one thousand year old culture
vanished
some of us might think if only they had
taken a leap and ventured out beyond
their island and gone to other places we
might still know what their culture was
and know more about them as a people
by the way this has happened before the
bronze age island of thera erupted and
erased a settlement that had been there
for multiple millennia
now this could be self-induced or it
could be from any number of natural
causes like an asteroid collision a
gamma-ray burst or a magnetic pull
reversal it really isn't a question of
if the earth will face one of these
events that threatens our species
survival
it's a question of when
i hope it doesn't happen but i'm playing
the odds
armed with this information don't you
think we should want some sort of
insurance
some backups to preserve humanity's
shout in the universe to not put all of
our eggs in one basket if we had humans
on another planet or on many planets for
example
then the survival of our species is much
more likely even if something happens to
the earth outside of our control
now a lot of people don't necessarily
like what i just said because it could
sound like we're trying to abandon the
earth run away from our problems instead
of addressing them that's not it at all
i mean when you finish backing up your
computer do you go to the nearest river
and chuck your computer into it thanks
for all the memories computer but i
don't need you anymore i've got a backup
now
that defeats the whole purpose no we
want to take excellent care of the earth
and go to space at the same time and
here's the best part i haven't told you
about yet going to space actually helps
the earth tremendously we have seen time
and time again that technologies
developed for space missions have
greatly helped life on earth
their applications are far-reaching and
not limited to the space missions to
which they were designed
to prove it to you here are some
technologies that we use every day on
earth that were originally developed for
space missions
cheaper and quieter artificial limbs
smartphone cameras
firefighting equipment baby formula
memory foam advanced solar cells better
lasik surgery water filters scratch
resistant lenses air purifiers the list
goes on and on
these technologies help us fight climate
change pollution and save lives every
day on earth we invented these things
because we decided to go to the moon and
to explore space
so we can't even imagine what we might
invent if we decide to go to mars
why did i start out talking about mars
when it's really my grand plan to
explore and settle the entire solar
system that i want to tell you about
well mars is the first leap we should
take in that journey
if we can get humans set up on mars it
will serve as a stepping stone to enable
further exploration into the rest of the
solar system
this should be our target
if we push ourselves towards
establishing a human presence on mars
it will be a giant leap in becoming a
truly space faring species with all the
benefits it brings earth really is by
far the best planet to live on in the
solar system but the solar system is
still worth our time and energy
as president kennedy said we do these
things not because they are easy but
because they are hard if we can start to
move humanity into the solar system we
can make those hard places more and more
livable while improving life here on
earth at the same time
i want to put a quote up from someone
who inspired a lot of people to think
more and more deeply about space
exploration
he said imagination will often carry us
to worlds that never were but without it
we go nowhere
ten thousand years ago people rarely
ventured beyond their birthplace
today we travel all over the planet
well at least when there's not a
pandemic going on
those people from 10 000 years ago would
have their minds blown by how far and
wide we travel today and people 1 000
years in the future will look back on us
and think the same thing that we would
have our minds blown by how far and wide
they travel throughout the solar system
think about that
we are the island
in the vast ocean that is our galaxy
i invite you to dream big with me
we could populate hundreds of planets
travel between worlds make great new
discoveries about our time and place in
the universe
you will even have an interstellar mars
address and a pen pal in the neighboring
star system
look i want to go to mars and see the
valles marineris a canyon 10 times the
size of the grand canyon that might be
an international park someday
i want to journey to saturn's moon titan
and fly around in the low gravity with
actual wings like a bird
i want to scuba dive on europa with
jupiter filling up most of the sky above
me and see if there's any life on the
ocean floor
i know i probably won't get to do any of
those things in my lifetime but i want
someone maybe you or your kids to be
able to do them i want humanity to
spread out in the solar system and
eventually the universe
and we are getting started on making
that happen right now
moxie is the first step
next on my to-do list is scaling up
moxie to support the first human mission
to mars that's what i'm working on right
now we've gotten started on the list but
there are a lot of problems facing us on
this journey still and we could use all
of your help in solving them
whether you can help from a scientific
or engineering standpoint or simply
spreading the message about the
importance of space and how it can
impact the earth in a positive way what
i want you to take away from this talk
is that this incredible vision of space
exploration will also pay enormous
benefits in making our home planet a
healthier and better place to live all
while improving the odds of survival for
our species
i think that's a dream worth pursuing
thank you